harry styles beauty brand pleasing just
got a new poster boy the los angeles
times report rock legend mick fleetwood
is the face of shroombloom harry's
latest collection of face and nail
products look at this
mick is one of harry's musical heroes he
grew up on fleetwood mac hello we all
did and describes mick as a magical man
of wizardry we cannot agree more look at
this right all these images
harry styles just for me does everything
right you know like i do from his albums
to his aesthetic to these products and
the way he he markets it his vision i
just think it's so one of a kind i also
think it's really on trend i think that
um my prediction
for the world everything is going to
become mushroom
really yes absolutely i'm i'm i know
that sounds silly but it's not their
mycelium is going to be the next great
resource it grows underneath the ground
it's what the mushrooms grow out of
but it's like trees and that it absorbs
all of our toxins and
you know people are making clothes out
of it um it's going to be the biggest
thing in fashion it's going to be like
the next great resource but i just think
shrooms will be trending real heavily
mushroom investing in mushrooms
that mushroom wow
well
turning to a food that doesn't feel i
mean as divisive um okay it's the food
of the future apparently they're creepy
they're crawly and they're today's food
news
we are
we are not feeling great about the
albuquerque journal reports that there's
one protein everyone's talking about and
that would be bugs insects have been in
diets around the world for ages but now
there's a new interest in insects as a
sustainable food choice
insects take less water and land to
cultivate than other animal proteins and
today we have been challenged with
seeing what all the buzz is about
with a bug flight
i don't
um
we have a special guest taster beth
nydick are you here i'm right here
you're gonna taste these
oh i am teenage boys and they always eat
like gross stuff so when this came up i
was like i gotta do it they do it mom's
gotta do it you know who loves eating
bugs um
it's a joke
no who
my aunt no
that's stupid oh my god well ironically
we don't have ants we have a tarantula
oh
my gosh look what i have here drew a
scorpion look
whoa
a whole i i crickets yes silkworms a
sago worm don't know what that is and
grasshoppers oh
i don't know if i can do it okay
all right beth are you gonna do one of
these i'm using barbecue sauce okay
you're using barbecue sauce and you're
going with the silkworm yes oh god drew
are you gonna do this
think potato chip
think think potato chip okay
oh god
oh god oh
okay oh god
i'm gonna lose my nerve
okay
i can't i the tarantula is really
freaking me i feel like you should have
sauce
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what are you gonna do
um let's see um i don't even wanna touch
it i'm gonna
oh she's doing it what are you doing
i'm not kidding it is totally delicious
oh so what does it taste like just
describe it like a crunchy treat
really
russ why don't you try it and you can
tell me what it tastes like oh there's
an aftertaste oh god
okay i'm gonna do one are you gonna do
one i ate that one there is an
aftertaste okay
[Applause]
did you see me i was so brave i was
um did you do the scorpion did anyone do
the scorpion will anyone do the scorpion
you raised your hand
oh my god yuck
i'm so excited
oh my god oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
that is incredible
this was so much fun um yeah well i have
to say this sort of bugged me
[Music]
you